so I'm gonna play slow chess it's Ally
chess classical arena the weekly
classical arena I'll probably just have
time for a game or two given there's an
hour left in the tournament's over a
thousand people playing 1266 people it's
a good turnout
sometimes forget how popular classical
chess is online seems like a lot more
bullet games are played but okay a lot a
lot of people play classical chess I'm
not accepting challenges at least for
the time being but I will say hi to
people hello - Elka's easy and eat an M
welcome let's play e4 he's rated 1500
I'll play play what I used to play
against the French the tirage variation
with Knight d2 have something a bit more
mainstream recently I've been playing a
lot of - Knights attack without playing
d4 but playing these two things so c5 is
our main line take on d5 and go for
Knight gf3 this is one of the openings I
learned in childhood like my first coach
taught me and okay Bishop b5 the usual
middle game position will result in
black heaven having an isolated Queens
pawn now Knight ge7 I've never seen
before
I assume he wants to play a six provoked
me to take and then recapture with the
night the problem is it blocks in his
bishop so I'm already trying to
calculate like castling a6
I take he takes back Corki one Bishop e7
I can win a pawn in that line I can win
a pawn right now - now what happens if I
just take the free pawn
if queen 85 I have Queen e2
I'm very curious I'm gonna take the pod
I think he I don't think this is a good
move the main line was Bishop d6 usually
the bishop should develop and then the
knight should go to e7 hello to more
people remember your name for challenges
I mean I'll probably stream longer than
this tournament lasts there's 57 minutes
57 minutes left in the tournament and
I'll probably stream for at least 90
minutes so I'll take challenges
afterwards now I'm tempted to play
Bishop III because his Knights are
superfluous which in this case isn't
that great for black let's play Bishop
d3 and if he moves the knight to one of
these squares then I have Mike b3 and
I'll hold on to the pawn could reinforce
it with Bishop e3 I was I have queenie
to check knight be three looks logical
zero viewers I think there's more than
zero viewers it's clearly people
watching maybe there were zero viewers
before I started Queenie
don't get Queenie seven well we could
trade Queens I don't really want to
trade Queens
especially when I'm playing a low rated
player but if I'm up upon it kind of
makes sense
King f1 could be interesting King I
found is awkward but it leaves his queen
awkwardly placed as well King f1
probably play Queen c7 and maybe like g3
preparing King g2 and also Bishop f4
okay let's play King f1 have some fun
this rook is slightly less pleased but
this configuration for black is not so
pretty either and one of the plans is
Bishop g5 Queen d2 and rook e1 and maybe
I can accomplish that before black
castles way deserve Rena Kings is it 5-0
I thought it was 1-0 pretty sure it's
one zero but I might be mistaken because
I did a test beforehand before I started
the stream and like the lag was I
couldn't deal with the lag it was
happening the last stream - and like I
think it's something with my streaming
software like OBS is just slowing
everything down which is why I would
rather play slower games until I figure
out what's going on with my computer
Bishop e6 so maybe he wants to Castle
queenside I'm gonna play Bishop g5 then
he plays f6 maybe Bishop f4 is better
Bishop f4 simple developing I don't
think he wants to Castle queenside and
my plan is Queen d2 rook e1 your first
real life rated game on Sunday that's
coming up tips for preparation don't
bring yourself out before before the
game like don't don't stay up all night
playing chess online get sleep eat well
exercise sometimes doing non chess
related things especially like a day or
two before a tournament will help you
help like put you in a good mindset
so but then of course okay sprinkle in
some tactics going with an open mind
there's no pressure plate to learn play
to win too but play to learn
Queenie to castling this should take a
six week to stuff I'm so sorry for
people's ears I might just fell off its
mic stand
Queenie - lets play Queenie - if he
castles I probably don't have Bishop
take a 6 but ok the king will be kind of
stuck on c8 so maybe I'll have something
at some point mm-hmm so he's keeping me
guessing
I mean g4 comes to mind g4
looking for moves which prevents black
from castling g4 is one of them the
night either has to go to h4 or h6 and
then he's attacking my g4 pawn but then
I can take on h4 it should be good if
nine h6 i play h3 wait so g4 9h for 90
gauge for Bishop take H 4
it feels weird to have my apology for in
that line
but what else to do man you still having
so much time to think let's play g4 oh
wait what am i doing
I almost played nine h4 they're
anticipating night I'm playing that h4
and then taking that would have been
disastrous like when you calculate a
line then you play the second moving the
line rather than the first move that's a
wake-up call that's caused by I don't
know what that's caused by a lack of
focus
maybe the nature of talking and playing
it's hard to keep up with the chats we
should have at least like one at least
one mod
only mods here our night pot and moobot
if you're in the chat and I know you and
your life feel free to say hi
let's take and okay now it's sort of a
debate
hey let's mondo heed ma to weed Bansky I
don't know Doug Wead in real life but I
feel like he's a trustworthy person okay
so the Bishop's pinch he wants a castle
does this work
g5 and if he castles I have Queen h5
threatening maid and threatening his
bishop it allows some future bishop h3
Abba thinking g1 let's do it
it's kind of risky because my king is
now more exposed but I just want to trap
his Bishop so looks okay
ninja welcome back do we you are a cool
guy but not as cool as the actual cool
guy
it's Adam I know a lot of Adams I know a
lot of David's too anyway Queeny try
should be on the horizon trying to
figure out like if he plays a move like
g6 those bishops just kind of sitting on
h4 and it's hard to attack if he plays
h6 I play Queen h5 and I create the pin
I love feeling I'm gonna win a piece but
then he's gonna get some compensation g4
I did not see coming
he wants to play something to d5 but
Queen h5 Queen d5 work g1 Bishop h3 King
e2 and his bishops still trapped
oh wait a minute he would have Bishop g4
in some lines but I'm not playing anyone
okay
let's go for this it's getting really
weird sent me a message I don't open up
messages on stream but you can open it
on my phone and take a look
Bishop h3 so kini ones like the only
move this is getting really messy
because he has some check you can also
play queen g4 and defend his bishop
but then I'm still up a pond that's a
great thing about being up a pond up
upon your up a pond yeah so he has like
three candidate atmosphere queenie seven
queenie six and queen g4 queenie 7 is
probably worst cuz when i play king d2
and then I have a threat of queen take
h4 and rookie one Lord efficient well
thanks for your comment that's so nice
it's flattering always appreciate the
kind words I also appreciate like
constructive criticism so if you have
anything that I can improve let me know
Queen e6 King D 2 and again I have the
double threat so I don't think we need
six helped him I mean he might play
queen g4 here but then rook e1 will come
with check
oh it's nn Adam I know Anna Anna Adam
yeah I'm I'm around I will be back I'll
probably come by next week
aren't you supposed to be in school it's
214
that's Friday to Friday as a school day
wait I completely forgot that Paul is
hanging but I have Ricky one thankfully
rookie one wins something I better win
something
yeah he should have played Bishop III
there's now 95 I just take on you five
okay I'm up a queen bishops attacked
wait let me me giving so many people so
much power today okay so I'm threatening
the bishop I have a oh I have a queen
and a knight for two rooks let's play
Bishop d6 preventing kingside castling
if he castles Queen side I'll have some
attack I'll play Queen seasick or Queen
to f3 threatening Bishop take a six my
bishop is just such a monster on d6 he's
probably gonna play like rook t8d e8
I'll play King f2 I can't take on a6
immediately can I take on c6 probably
not I'm King f2
if he had like a knight on g7 I could
take on c6 it would be made into it's a
common I forgot what they call this the
classic Queen sacrifice but doesn't work
here because this team escapes but if I
can take on any six first that would be
nice that I'm threatening me than one
that's the thing like when you have an
extra queen even though he has two rooks
wait oh I I think I said Queen and I
have Queen and Bishop for the two rooks
which is also just as good its thing
about these positions if you start
attacking I just have more pieces to
attack with then black has pieces to
defend if he takes it's made in one if
he doesn't take it still might be made
in one if he moves the knight somewhere
it could be made in one so there's not
too many ways to defend here yah Nev
thanks for the sub this first sub of
today nice is it primetime just after 2
p.m. on a Friday I guess maybe that's
sort of prime time because it's like
Europe Europe would be what like not too
late in the evening shout out to all the
Europeans watching Europe is like 6 to
10 hours ahead then ok
reasonable time oh it's tick
PD bull talk thanks for the sub always
like when people just like share all the
places they're from in the chat nice to
see it's a very diverse audience I
really want to meet the King ignite c5
King take d6 not seeing anything forced
okay Queen up six losses what did you
his night is strong
so night c-5 king take t6 maybe queen a3
let's do that
sacking the pawn the pollen was a goner
anyway I can probably just pre move
between a three and now his Kings a bit
stuck my pieces are swarming all around
he has one check and then I play King g3
and he'll have no checks
now I'm threatening a bunch of different
discoveries so he could run backwards or
forwards if he runs four words I think
it's force made after 93 King got five
Queen c5 and yeah that's like made them
two or three because my pawn plays a
crucial role defending f6 my Queen plays
a role by King plays a role my bishop
plays a role everything plays a role he
has one legal move here and then Queen
c5 or even Queen a5 pretty much the same
thing
this is the fifth-ranked meet as opposed
to the back rank meets so I'll get at
least another gamer to in just over 38
minutes left in the tournament why don't
I play much higher rated players wait
this is not for us mate or is it he's 95
in the end I've got the rook defense I
mean when I play tournaments and I join
late I'm paired against players with low
scores so that's one of the issues with
playing tournaments like this and play
h4 quiet move cuz I want to keep my pod
if I had started the tournament from the
beginning I probably would have played
some stronger players at some points
which is one of my one of the things I
should do more if I should actually make
an effort to plan ahead start a
tournament from the beginning and play
the previous stream I did I played the
chest comm arena Kings it was like a
three minute tournament I was playing a
lot of strong players played cops key a
few times he beat me with the London
then I played the London against him and
he beat me again
it was devastating his for pot sir I am
planning to go to London
speaking of London the the location but
I haven't finalized plans okay where's
meats I see one pretty mate if he takes
with Brooke Bishop c8 his mates if he
takes with pawn Queen f7 his mates if he
takes on g5 Knight g4 his mates I was
working with a student yesterday a
relative beginner and he was saying how
impressed he is it's like seeing strong
players be able to find maiden ones
really quickly all part of childhood
training okay so those what we were
opening in this line black is usually
supposed to play Bishop d6 even though
it loses a tempo after I take the knight
can then developed you seven and
castling and it's a possible position
back to tournament I moved up about 100
places